[Música]
Hoy es el gran día de cierre en Israel
miles de manifestantes bloquearon las
principales calles de la nación hebrea
menos de 12 horas después que se
ratificara una ley que limita las
circunstancias en las que se puede
destituir a un Primer Ministro
más que enojo los israelíes Están
preocupados de los alcances que esta ley
le pueda dar al ultraderechista Benjamín
tenemos miedo de que los cambios que el
gobierno haga no nos dejen otra opción
más que mudarnos
de ninguna manera permitiremos que
Israel se convierta en una autocracia o
un lugar donde no haya democracia Así
que estamos aquí en las calles en
cualquier momento que podamos para
expresar nuestra verdadera preocupación
por este lugar que amamos
la ley ratificada el miércoles protege
al premiere de la posibilidad de ser
considerado no apto para gobernar por su
juicio de corrupción y por las denuncias
de conflicto de intereses por su
implicación en la reforma esta ley es
solo una de las docen de leyes que
conforman la polémica reforma judicial
de netanyahu una reforma que ha traído
un insistente rechazo por parte de la
población en jornadas de protestas que
ya suman 10 semanas y que ha sido
señalada de querer controlar la Corte
Suprema por medio de limitaciones a los
veredictos del alto tribunal
llegamos con una declaración muy
específica para el jefe de la policía de
israelí y para los altos funcionarios de
la policía no se conviertan en una
policía política no sirvan a los
fascistas
la gran movilización que entre La Vid
convocó a familias completas junto con
menores de edad terminó en otras
ciudades con detenciones y
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes
[Música]